ça c'est tous les corps de métier et
dans tous ces corps de métier on a
besoin d'IA et on fait de l'IA 2023
Semaine de l'Industrie imp possible
d'échapper à l'intelligence artificielle
le Technocentre Renault en a fait une
force et l'objectif de cet après-midi
mettre en avant une entreprise
résolument tourné vers l'innovation
technologique je veux montrer aux jeunes
que Renault ben on n'est pas que des
plieurs de tô on n'est pas que des gens
qui qui faisont des révisions et on est
aussi des gens qui faisont de la haute
technologie et qui faisont de l'IA et on
espère bien attirer les jeunes les plus
dynamiques et les plus malins pour faire
de l'intelligence artificielle avec nous
en mettre dans notre véhicule pour qu'il
soit de plus en plus intelligent en
mettre dans la fabrication pour que la
fabrication soit plus rapide et de
meilleure qualité les visiteurs du jour
des étudiants d'ingénieur en licence pro
robotique outre l'intervention sur
l'intelligence artificielle ils ont pu
visiter le site et découvrir de nouveaux
métiers une journée qui leur donnera
peut-être des idées de projets futur
c'est un endroit très grand et que
franchement que j'aimerais peut-être un
jour revenir travailler ici c'est
intéressant on découvre d'autres
domaines c'est c'est pertinent prochaine
visite jeudi 30 novembre le Technocentre
accueillera des étudiants de butut ils
seront sensibilisés sur le métier de
développeur
logiciel